yo what's up guys nasher here coming to
you from seattle as you may know there's
a new nhl team in town and today we're
showing you behind the scenes first
things first today it is bright and
early here at 8 30 a.m the morning skate
is getting ready to start up we're
heading to the arena now and we'll see
what's going down
we've just arrived here at climate
pledge arena it is looking beautiful
from the outside and even better here on
the inside ever wonder what it looks
like to be on an nhl bench well we're
out here chilling nice little touch here
in seattle for each of their warm-up
pucks we have the official warm-up
seattle versus new york so when you're
taking home a puck from the game you
know where it's from so climate pledge
arena is all about the environment right
this is a fully electric zamboni usually
when we're down here you smell the
gasoline it's very loud you can see
quiet zamboni smells perfect
beauty
and of course we have the seattle
crafting locker room now there's some
top secret stuff going on there right
now we're not able to enter but let's
walk down this tunnel behind you you
just feel powerful walking down a puddle
like this not only that we have these
crazy sweets so see i don't have the
optional skate this morning the rangers
are in full force
the razor's coming
not a lot of people have got to touch
the seattle cracking ice and we are one
of the few all of this ice is from
reused rainwater they collect it bring
it down here two jumbos above us you
just cannot beat these vibe here we are
we are joined with philip grubauer here
of the seattle kraken we've had a good
couple games here starting tonight how
you feeling pretty good it's uh amazing
to play in here for sure what's it been
like in the locker room kind of building
a new culture here in seattle it's been
unbelievable to be part of that process
and just to see the excitement in the
city and before we started playing the
first game here was
incredible playing a couple home games
in a row it's it's pretty cool and
special and i think
it translates to the excitement in the
locker room for the guys as well tell me
about the city of seattle what's what's
something we should go check out after
the game today lake union is uh
incredible obviously you go up the space
needle if you have time there's so many
great spots you you actually you guys uh
came in at the right time because it's
actually sunny today yesterday it's only
been raining so just drive around the
lake i think that's pretty cool to see
as well and mountaineer in the back it's
pretty special awesome man wish you the
best of luck tonight thanks again for
everything and uh yeah that's phil
gru-rower here with the seattle crack we
explored the arena we got on the ice we
got to talk to our boy grubauer what an
unreal morning here in seattle but now
it is time to explore the rest of the
city so we're going to go to the market
we're going to grab some lunch show you
guys around
we just saw the fish throw live in
person this is where the seattle kraken
announced their picks
fish came over flipped it over bada bing
dude it is a whole different world here
in seattle we got the cats on the violet
i don't know what is happening but this
place is sick
markets food flying fish you name it
they have it we found a little card shop
here at the market the owner in there is
super nice we're gonna walk in show you
guys around and uh maybe buy a couple
packs little 1990 nhl hockey cards dude
the seals those jerseys are the best all
right we've got our packs we're gonna
pop these open uh we'll see if we can
recognize any of the players in here
depending on who we get and a mike
madonna that is a banger north star's
jersey and all let's go grab some food
starting so we explore the market found
some food we're at athenian here
beautiful looking food eat food alfredo
we've got the fried you can't beat the
view i think we've got the ferris wheel
which i think we're gonna head to next
yeah i don't think i've been on a ferris
wheel since i was seven years old this
is fire man seattle seattle literally
has it all we have made it to the top
let's go what a day this is the perfect
way to get ready for the kraken versus
rangers tonight we've seen a lot of
things here in seattle we had to walk by
the gum wall i thought it was just a
small little piece of a wall what is
going on here
best way to get around seattle right now
we're gonna go right to the rig on these
little scoots let's get it
we are buzzing let's go
in the arena first stop we gotta get
decked out check out the lair no doubt
best merch best branding in the nhl
looking around i mean
this is too much there is a spinning
floating jersey rack rosso slop
custom cracking jersey coming soon
[Applause]
we got the hook up here we're gonna head
to the media hole they got us a little
spot for warming head down there get a
view of the boys let's go we're gonna
get you guys the best view ever of the
warming
[Music]
is
number one
i mean that's just a nasty snipe
zero angle looks like it might have hit
crossbar but no dead back then
[Music]
i want to start here in seattle a couple
good chances both ways
onesie over the rangers right now we got
a good view of the goal
we'll see what happens here in a second
thank you so much
great speech you enjoyed the game you
appreciate it dude ohio represents out
here
[Music]
what up how are you doing brother good
how are you
what is this what's going on here so i
made a science
[Music]
i think it's official ollie and jacob on
the bench they're worldwide
[Applause]
big period there for the kraken tied the
game up got to see it from multiple
angles i was up top john was down low
time for the biggies we have the
concessions coming in the important
thing to note about the concessions here
it is cashier-less there's cameras that
follow you around the store and you
don't have to do anything you just walk
in into your credit card grab whatever
you want off the shelves and then you're
good to go
here we go what are we feeling today
don't mind if i do how is it watching me
right now i have no idea all right water
and just like that no cashier needed
we're out of here
there's just no way there's no way wow
the future is now we got our skittles
there's plants on the walls there's no
cashiers this is a dream come true and a
good hockey game to go along with it we
need a seattle crack and win
i'm not the curves okay i'm not showing
up and getting them a loss
let's go now we're going to the press
labs we're going all over this building
the fans are to the left the ice is to
the right
watch the gate from here that was
actually nasty adam fox with a little
pop-pop double toe drag to the snipe
he's disgusting we need a miracle let's
go
how have they not scored one of these
one minute pick up your phone
hold it
[Music]
final score three to one
r.i.p
and that is going to do it here in
seattle a tough loss to end the night
they just couldn't beat eagle he popped
off at the end there were so many good
chances but it was too little too late
it was a blast here in seattle though
getting to hang out with you guys
explore the arena and show you
everything behind the scenes here at
climate pledge we'll definitely come
back for another seattle game to prove
that we are not the curse so a crazy
night still a good night thank you guys
for hanging out i'm nashor with vr open
ice and we're out peace